you're doing something that I find
intriguing you are doing live tapings
yeah of undateable huh which feels like
quite a challenge
I mean you missed a cue the the at once
on the show not once I missed I missed
the cue in the premiere of this season
where I was supposed to be in a scene
and I just wasn't in the scene right was
this during the drinking or non drinking
faith this honestly honestly they told
me I wasn't in it
so I went over towards the bar there's a
bar that's a set yeah we have no but we
have an actual bar now on the show it's
a party over there some friends so I
stuck being like hey are you doing hey
that's a fake moon by the way you know
you can have fake stuff out of them
dateable we made it yeah and then the
stage manager comes up and goes Brenton
right you have to be in the scene and I
went no no I'm not and I thought about
it later I worked as a PA for stage
managers I understand by go and they
know what's right and I don't and as the
talent why was I questioned everybody
everybody was like getting the scene I
was like nah I'm good oh that's enough
TV Jamie I think we have I think we have
the clip when you just didn't show up
for this let's take a look at that it's
been a rough day yeah Brent left because
he's so sad
he should be back any minute right now
right no I was so upset with me that's
maybe my handiwork huh
yeah yeah you've been a real jerk
he should be here soon no Mike there's
many people waiting for him whatever as
awkward as that relationship is it's
definitely not as awkward as that one
right there so you did you just to
understand how easy it is for us to
break character he started calling me
Brent when my name's Justin on the show
and they all were like where's Brent
where's Brent and to most people who
were watching show they're like who's
Brent I was like they just know Justin
and I actually got to the point where I
was close enough where I saw that
happening and I still didn't go out
there cuz I was like you guys told me I
wasn't in it we're telling you're in it
now so you knew that you were supposed
to be on and you're behind this pin
you're not really refusing to go out and
you're just leaving them there on live
television yeah I trained you well
you need to be good I'm doing my best to
be good undateable airs live Fridays at
8:00 on NBC and Brent's first stand-up
special
I am Brent Morin how'd you come up with
that title I'm people Navy don't know
when you tune in for the first 15
minutes this is just an empty stage
Lauren will be available for streaming
on Netflix December first shove a forest
[Applause]